let's talk about condoms everybody loves
condoms right there is some new condom
technology that's right the Galactic cap
which claims to be stronger and safer
than traditional condoms and enable
better sensitivity we've got an image of
the cap
okay so what's happening here should we
have put a parental warning on this
video sorry guys sorry ladies all right
so this but it's basically like a tiny
little cap that goes on the top of the
penis the rest of the penis is exposed
so you're gonna get more sensitivity
everyone in the studio is really getting
a kick out of this thing it's most
sensitive though the tip of the tip yeah
isn't that what really so generally a
little lower than the tip of the tip you
know you mean below the tip okay good
talk that's it for us yeah okay so the
condom it compromises two parts a
u-shaped polyurethane adhesive film that
wraps around the penis that's what you
saw there it's sort of like a plastic
around a finger and a cap that sticks to
firmly trap the semen so a guy basically
could wear this all the time and be
ready for sex at any time do you think
men would ever women have to be on birth
control you know I mean women have to
have taken responsibility for their
reproductive health their sexual health
men it doesn't seem to me who would be
able I'm going to wear it for a long
time it might happen yeah that's gonna
happen people are gonna get AIDS and
they're gonna get gonorrhea herpes
because this only protects against
pregnancy it doesn't protect against any
STDs so right well I guess there's some
question whether it'll protect against
some of the STDs because if it does trap
the semen it does trap the semen so the
skin on skin stuff could still be so
there's some questions related to that
but just be a little clearer about how
this thing actually works so you could
literally be wearing it all the time and
then when you want to have sex if you
can find someone that's willing to do it
with you you peel off the paper backing
on the cap and stick it to the
polyurethane
to secure the bond between the two
between the two you know because the
penis is an organ well known for always
having the right amount of friction and
always being dry yeah I love that they
emphasize that you can wear it all the
time anytime but I think it's crazy to
think that a woman will be like oh you
know for the first time you know getting
you know heavy petting or whatever and
then all of a sudden like petting you
don't hear that one too of a baby
necking up it down and you see it in
your like your milk oh [ __ ] and also I'm
thinking like you premeditated this did
you use it with somebody else before me
like no not happening you're not getting
laid if you wear that right and okay so
okay so for you guys if you were on a
date with a guy and then you know you
got back to to his place to your place
wherever you are and then you got naked
and he already had one of those on you'd
be like what the guys don't like about
cleanliness ya know some dirty STD test
if you're gonna be wearing that that's
not yeah all right well I guess I don't
have to ask you my final question which
was do you think this condom will
finally revolutionize safe sex it sounds
like that's not going to be maybe in
like really committed long-term
relationships or whatever where like say
the pill is giving you like the girl an
allergic reaction or morning sickness
like pills are [ __ ] awful so if this
is an alternative to using the pill and
like committed monogamous relationships
sure yeah but going back to what I said
earlier for guys it's just seems like
guys just aren't responsible enough and
would you even would you even trust the
guy if there was something that was
really like that small I mean would you
trust him to you know to me like you
turn your head for a sec for all you
know he ripped that thing off and you
may not even know as I do that why would
you want to get me pregnant well he just
may want more sensation he's being so
yeah we [ __ ] I like you how you have
so much faith in men that's Kim no faith
in men Lissette a lot of faith in men
[Music]